House Republican leaders came down hard
on one of their own last night
Iowa Congressman Steve King was stripped
of his committee assignments less than a
week after making a comment to the New
York Times that was widely seen as
racist King's punishment is a rare move
that often leads lawmakers to resign
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning Republican
leaders could tell that the Democrats
who now control the house were about to
take action themselves and so they
decided to get out in front of it and
punish King after ignoring years of
inflammatory rhetoric congressman King
was informed by phone that he was being
removed from the powerful judiciary and
agriculture committees do you understand
the decision was made by House GOP
leader Kevin McCarthy and other top
Republicans these are not the first time
we've heard these comments that is not
the party of Lincoln it was definitely
not America it was in an interview with
the New York Times that King appeared to
show sympathy with racist ideologies
musing quote white nationalist white
supremacist Western civilization how did
that language become offensive I would
say to my colleague that the terms are
offensive because the concepts are evil
by last night three House Democrats had
submitted resolutions to officially
admonish King who argued his quote was
misconstrued and that he opposes white
supremacy leader McCarthy's decision to
remove me from committees he said is a
political decision that ignores the
truth but the nine term conservative
congressman has a history of racially
insensitive comments including this one
without immigrants in 2013 for everyone
who's a valedictorian there's another
hundred out there that they weigh a
hundred and thirty pounds and they've
got calves the size of cantaloupes
because they're hauling 75 pounds of
marijuana across the desert now
Republican leaders like Senator Mitch
McConnell are urging him to find another
line of work he ought to resign and move
on and let someone else who represents
American values take his seat one
Republican who did not weigh in was
President Trump
King was an early supporter of the
president's immigration stance but the
president said yesterday he hasn't been
following the controversy John Democrats
said that Republicans ought to condemn
some of his inflammatory rhetoric to
Nancy thank you and just to remind the
reason white supremacy is offensive is
it's the idea that whites are superior
to other races that's at the heart of
this I would agree that's offensive or
anything that's not a big problem Party
and some of the leaders now showing some
courage in her denouncing them that
Romney's speaking out the way he did
courage and pressure yeah yeah